a mother's day the one day a year where
people all over the world pay tribute to
mom mama mom or ma
but how did it all begin
enter anna jarvis the founder of
mother's day who came to despise her own
holiday
anna jarvis really really loved her
mother her mother dies in 1905 and in
1907 she really starts this campaign
that we need to have a day in honor of
what mothers do that's dr catherine
antolini she's a historian and wrote a
book about anna she always identified
herself as anna jarvis the founder of
mother's day and in 1914 after six years
in state by state campaigning jarvis's
dream came true president woodrow wilson
officially designated the second sunday
of may as mother's day hooray
right
jarvis felt wilson was taking credit for
her efforts and he wasn't the only
source of her ire anna had a really
wonderful enemies list she was mad at
the candy industry and she was mad at
the floor industry she was mad at all
these charities she also turned on some
of her early allies including john
wanamaker a business tycoon who saw a
commercial opportunity in mother's day
he started putting the holiday on
everything even dishes at his restaurant
jarvis did not approve
she ordered this mother's day salad and
once the salad arrived mrs jarvis just
dumped it on the floor and walked out
that was not what the day was supposed
to be what exactly was the day supposed
to be so it really wasn't meant to be go
out restaurant by all these flowers and
greeting cards and candy and gifts just
go home and spend the day with your
mother that's all she wants i wonder
what anna jarvis would say about the way
mother's day celebrated today she would
still be defending it against
commercialization we celebrate this
holiday in ways that she doesn't think
we should hear that people don't forget
about anna jarvis the mother of mother's
day and please send your mom a card
for her a greeting card would be
insincere it would be cheap it would be
lazy if you can't go home then you know
write a letter to her don't just send a
card got it write your mom a handwritten
letter she deserves it don't you think
you